si demain vous étiez isolé quelque part
sur une île déserte par exemple c'est de
la fiction mais quel film emporteriez
vous avec vous la procurer des films de
danse et le carnet qu'il est tout à
l'heure je considère par exemple de
gérer seulement les enfants du paradis
pour comme critique le film qui m'a plus
frapper ça c'est l'arrivée du train en
gare de louis lumière agence bourse car
fait ça fait partie de votre
cinémathèque préférées oui tu dois en 34
de dire j'avais fait ça va marquer puis
l'a vu hier et je re bon pour moi avec
asphalt jungle film qui vous a le plus
marqué mais n'est pas du tout que c'est
l'horreur de mur nous votre plus grand
souvenir de cinéma éveillé claude
lelouch est ce que c'est ça reste qu'on
passe les sig règne ce film de michaël
kalatozov que j'ai vu à moscou en 1957
et qui m'a donné envie de faire du
cinéma c'est à ce moment là on assiste
en au tournage de sim que j'ai dit voilà
le métier je veux je crois qu'il y a
dans les contrebandiers de moonfleet et
dans sa simplicité certainement une des
choses et plus capitale du cinéma pour
moi m'a demandé un jour quel est le
meilleur film du monde
j'ai dit c'est lui nu pourquoi les nus
parce que y'a rien c'est des mains qui
transportent de l'eau et le drame c'est
quand on a renversé l'eau c'est rien n'y
a rien il ya de l'eau a mais qu'il n'y a
pas d'eau pour arroser ses carottes et
pendant une heure et demie m les plus
grands metteurs en scène même chaplin il
n'a pas pu faire ça parce qu'il a
toujours utilisé des artifices
j'entendais tout à l'heure que à la
foire était producteur de la poison
c'est un des films que j'ai préféré que
je préfère avec michel simon qui est un
acteur peut-être mon acteur
que j'idolâtre et la poison est un film
sublime dont je me souviens quand
j'étais jeune et que qui me restait il
ya des films que je vais voir savez
chaque fois qu'on les projets comme
un film comme fenêtre sur cour dite coco
un film comme le carrosse d'or de renoir
si ça passe quatre fois dans l'année à
paris je vais voir les quatre fois donc
en tout je les essaie de les voir 25 30
fois que je connais tous les démarrages
de musique je connais tous les je peux
même reconnaître la compétition c'est la
copie qui est passée la dernière en date
parce qu'à une rayure sur talbot bill
alors donc les 400 coups c'est votre
film de chevet c'est un film que j'adore
que je profondément mon coeur comme tout
le monde a pleuré quand on quand j'ai vu
les quatre cents coups c'était déchirant
la grande illusion
l'évangile selon saint matthieu le plus
beau film du monde le plus beau film du
monde qui a persuadé les plus grands
metteurs en scènes du monde à faire du
cinéma comme scorsese ou des mecs comme
ça je vous ai demandé à chacun de
choisir vos films de chevet et jean
jacques beineix a choisi au petit bijou
un grand vin chaud grand bijoux bobbies
enfants du paradis de carnets mais ce
film est parfait ce film est parfait
parce que il mélange tous les genres
c'est une histoire policière
c'est une histoire plus beau film sur
eux sur le théâtre sur le mensonge sur
l'illusion sur l'amour moi j'aime bien
les vieux films
comme au temps autant en emporte le vent
par exemple ou sur les quais ou un
tramway nommé désir
et puis des films étrangers ainsi que le
rappelle que je consacre le mur ouest s
appelle à une nonne en 48
je ne sais pas par quel hasard passe au
champo le jour se lève de carnets aussi
totalement envoûté par un film j'ai
l'impression que je ressens ce que ça
peut être le cinéma et j'en suis
ressorti j'étais prendre un d un café je
suis retourné à la séance suivante
je tournais le soir ça que j'ai vu trois
fois le même jour à make america d'elia
kazan évidemment la règle du jeu parce
que c'est le film absolue c'est parce
que renoir 1939 c'est toute la nouvelle
écriture moderne il ya je ne sais
combien de cinéastes aujourd'hui qui se
réclament de renoir avec ce thème ce qui
le film que je revois peut-être le plus
souvent ce qui pourrait être un signe ça
serait un film de vincente minnelli qui
s'appelle les ensorcelés avec kirk
douglas sinon ça pourrait être un manque
évident ça pourrait être un rêve ou où
les fantômes de madame muir
[Musique]